everyone and welcome to another Bitcoin
video this video is gonna be expanding
on privacy within Bitcoin
so I've already covered the basics of
privacy through the Bitcoin protocol
paper though I was doing my best to keep
those videos in that series basically
opinion free because that's a toshi
paper itself was actually very opinion
and in you know not political in any way
it was just a scientific paper so I
wanted to do my best I did slip a few
times and I even did in the privacy
video but I did want to expand on that a
little bit more in a completely separate
video so you guys know what you're
getting into so the topic of Bitcoin
privacy or anonymity is actually very
interesting because some people argue
that bitcoins anonymity is like
dangerous while other people are
actually displeased that bitcoin is
actually not anonymous so if you did
watch that previous video then you saw
you know the actual model difference is
I'll show that same figure again here
the model that Bitcoin protocol uses
isn't really more anonymous it's just a
different structure it's a different
model our current finance model ties
identities to transactions which then go
through a trusted third party which then
get to the counterparty the public is
just simply kept outside of this right
there they have no access to this and
the new model identities are kept
separate and transactions literally go
through the public in the form of this
public ledger now
identities are kept separate but this
isn't actually necessarily more private
than the first
despite this bar that denotes identities
being kept separate just like the public
isn't necessarily always kept separate
from your transactions today so what is
the difference really and what is this
notion of privacy so first we should
consider privacy so at the outset some
along the lines it became acceptable
that you did not deserve privacy anymore
somewhere along the lines they became
like a rule that you couldn't be private
anymore in the name of security in the
name of security you can't be private I
mean the the argument today is that with
privacy criminals can conduct crimes
easier and catching them is just more
difficult so let's consider the NSA in
the CSS obviously staying for National
Security Agency and the central security
service their slogan is defending our
nation securing our future their mission
statement vision and values are as
follows the national security agencies /
central security service NSA / CSS leads
the US government in cryptology that
encompasses both signals intelligence
and information assurance products and
services and enables computer network
operations in order to gain a decision
advantage for the nation and our allies
under all circumstances their vision
globale Cryptologic dominance through
responsive presence and network
advantage their values we will protect
national security interest by an hearing
to the highest standards of behavior
alright so we'll just kind of encompass
the CSS within NSA and call them all the
same NSA currently the NSA is able to
track all payments directly all of your
online activity directly and have it all
linked to your identity as Andreas
Antonopoulos put it the NSA is well
thought of as instead of the National
Security Agency the national storage
agency now see peer-to-peer justice and
security is also a sort of transaction
that we've always traditionally needed a
you guessed it trusted third party for
people have to trust this third party to
not be malicious or to overstep their
boundaries their mission vision and
values however all allow for stepping as
far as you will let them I mean their
goal is very clear
to achieve their goal they will step as
far as possible it's very much like any
organization at all I mean look at
Google Google there's a team of
engineers their job is to test limits
that's what they do
Google finds itself under litigation and
prosecution fairly often and they're
constantly pushing boundaries as an
organization it is their mission to do
this and to push this is why they're
successful the NSA is no different I
look at even you know like my own
business syntax where I collect
sentiment information you know across
the internet and honestly it would be
really neat if I had like a true
internet you know firehose right and I
could play with that kind of data I mean
you could get some really epic results
with that kind of stuff and I bet the
NSA has a field day with the data that
they have and I bet the scientists
working on that data really truly love
working on that data and they don't
necessarily see it as prying into
people's lives and all this kind of
stuff I mean I truly just love data and
I would really love working with such a
large data set right the problem of
course is that people must trust that
this data will be used for good rather
than evil overstepping boundaries is
like pretty much inevitable with
scientists and engineers
that's just plain what they do and the
NSA is no different but I will just
stress that neither is Google or
anything like that but the difference
here is that the government doesn't
necessarily have a watchdog like Google
does see it's funny with all this
Snowden stuff because a lot of people
were commenting and still are that you
know all this stuff that Snowden you
know told us about hey we already knew
about this I mean this wasn't news you
know it's just sad because we've become
extremely passive about our privacy from
the government and we allow ourselves to
be really easily distracted I mean yeah
people move for a while that this sort
of thing was happening and it was a
subject of conversation but quickly
people forgot and moved on but so we
needed a reminder we need something like
a you know remember the NSA is watching
day right once a year just a little
holiday to remind us that that this
stuff is happening so back to this
notion of the national storage agency
what they do is collect store and
analyze the data that they get if you
become say a wanted suspect it's
basically like doing a search on you and
the NSA search engine and start pulling
up dirt and information on you the info
is already there they don't have to
really start anything so to protect you
best if the motives were truly
beneficial to the people then this
really does seem like the most efficient
way I mean just gather all the
information possible then you have the
best weapon against crime you must be
absolutely sure however that the NSA has
your best interests at heart at all
times and will never abused their
authority a good example of how
Authority abuse can get out of hand is
with someone like Roger Vere who at the
ripe age of twenty I ran for California
State Assembly he vowed to not take a
salary since the salary would have been
paid through taxes which he felt were
theft and during a debate he argued his
you know position on tax the war on
drugs and even called the ATF basically
ATF agents a bunch of jackbooted thugs
and murderers and this was in light of
the wake of Texas law Turing's from
there he was targeted no surprise by
offended ATF agents the problem is these
ATF agents didn't target him as
civilians they targeted him as ATF
agents using their resources knowledge
and networking as ATF agents not as
civilians to attack Roger Vere this is
where things begin to go a bit awry and
power abuse occurs you know humans are
emotional emotional and fallible often
choosing to abuse their power in these
kinds of situations so after a bunch of
digging or really not that much digging
was required the ATF agencies found a
pest-control product that basically
acted like a firecracker to scare away
deer and birds from crops like corn so
the ATF agents prosecuted Roger ver
alone while the producer and other
big-name sellers like Cabela's and all
this were completely left out of it and
then nothing and then really the the
true disgusting part was during one of
the trials
or hearings the prosecutor agreed that
veera really only need to pay a fine and
do some community service since the
crime was not that intense and at at
that point during the trial one of the
ATF agents literally pounds his hand on
the table and shouts but you didn't hear
the things he said this clearly shows
that you know this was more about the
distasteful statements he made towards
the ATF agents than the actual
firecrackers themselves that was
actually you know he's on trial for
because he can say whatever he wants
about the ATF agents that's freedom of
speech right but in this case we can
clearly see that there was not freedom
of speech and there was definitely abuse
of power I personally would have to
disagree with fair if he truly feels
that every single ATF agent is a
murderer though it is clear to me that
many indeed are corrupt and actually do
truly enjoy violence and killing I
certainly wouldn't make such a sweeping
statement as if like every ATF agent is
like that but if I did I should be
protected from prosecution under free
speech from that exclamation during the
trial I mean the entire case you know
should have been just completely thrown
out as it's a clear conflict of interest
but that would never happen
as the conflict of interest spreads more
than just through the ATF agents it's
through the entire legal system
networking favors in general corruption
so back to the NSA let's talk about this
model so in the current model everything
is tracked automatically stored and it's
like based on your identity nice and
easy
what about the Bitcoin model how does
that work so despite looking like
identity is clearly just separated from
all of this that's not really quite the
case some of the more prominent members
of the Bitcoin community like Andreas
Antonopoulos are actually kind of
adamantly vocal about the fact that
bitcoin is not anonymous and it should
be anonymous and so we can view history
and see that transactions in Bitcoin are
hardly anonymous and the ability to
locate and track users on the blockchain
is indeed possible the real difference
between the current privacy model in the
Bitcoin privacy model is that ongoing
tracking of people just for the sake of
tracking as
storing information on people beforehand
is not as possible still as possible but
not as easy it's much more difficult to
track and tie everything together so you
can kind of think of his actually it's
sort of like proof of work right roof of
work basically makes it hard so it
becomes extremely cumbersome to cheat
the network because of the amount of
work required to do so this new privacy
model makes it so digging up information
on someone takes a little bit more work
and literally more CPU power so now that
transactions are not by identity but
rather by the transaction hashes and
public keys the way to find someone and
learn about their activity is instead to
trace payments going linearly through
everything following the path of the
payment naturally this is going to take
a lot more effort in terms of tracking
but there is actually no privacy there
right everything is public on the
blockchain and uses you know and using
traditional investigation techniques
information can indeed being acquired
here so again the only major difference
is the ability to easily log everything
that occurs in this new form logging
everyone's transactional details tying
these actions to the original person
just simply becomes more labor intensive
or CPU intensive that's that
investigation in the sense of
investigating a singular person is still
very much a possibility especially the
fact that this is a public ledger the
interesting part is this entire debate
to me is that people are sent keep
saying that criminals and drug lords you
are using Bitcoin as their like main
tool for hiding from regulators and law
enforcement
how quickly can we forget about the
trustee dollar bill the dollar bill our
cash is far more anonymous and even can
be used online but first let's just
remember the anonymity of the dollar
bill and also understand that it's cash
that is the main tool for drug lords
right right and criminals not Bitcoin
cash is preferred even to Bitcoin even
if you even though you could make the
argument while most criminals don't know
about Bitcoin or don't know how to use
it yet well even if they did the
preferred method would be cash because
cash comes
more anonymity and less of a trail so
not only can you commit crimes and keep
cash on hand you can also even use your
bank to help or like a service like
Western Union to make transfers these
cash services are really far superior to
using Bitcoin and cash is far more
easily laundered than Bitcoin cash is
used everywhere and it's almost
impossible to prove where that cash
actually came from like tracking that
dollar bill is pretty hard with Bitcoin
not only is it harder to launder it's
almost impossible to remove your
fingerprint so to speak from it the
trail of addresses is completely public
you can't really fake that one and it
can't be tracked so if you're truly
laundering money in the sense of you
know you're you're trying to get dirty
money clean that because that's really
what you're doing when you're laundering
money let's remember the definition of a
money laundering okay you're you're
usually going to be buying physical
goods or exchanging money for money
somehow when you do this with Bitcoin
you're being tracked you you just simply
aren't constantly being tracked if
you're a known criminal right that's the
difference so the issue is with
regulation comes these human rights
violations it's your human right to have
some privacy and not be tracked 24/7
it's your human right that just because
some ATF agents are not fond of you they
can't just abuse their power to get back
at you and some childish immature
fashion it is the argument of the FBI
and the NSA and just general government
that it is worth it to track a thousand
people to catch one criminal easier I
bet most of them would agree that ten
thousand or a million or whatever it's
still worth it if you can catch that
criminal that's their belief and if it's
not your belief you really should should
resist it but regulation of money
generally
isn't there to protect the consumers
either right these the costly
regulations in place that are inhibiting
business from occurring are these anti
money laundering and this whole
requirement to register as a money
transmitting business right so when I
tell people I run a fund with Bitcoin
right which was started for almost near
free I explain that
would cost in the millions to do the
same thing with traditional money now
most people think that these regulations
are in place to protect people right
there's the regulation that costs in the
millions has nothing to do with whether
or not would be a competent money
manager a fraud or a schemer trying to
get you instead these constantly in
inhibiting regulations are just there to
protect quote/unquote against money
laundering none of the major criminals
of Bitcoin have been impossible to catch
even the non criminals committing no
crime at all are being prosecuted see
Charlie Shrem and are easily being
prosecuted with already pre-existing
laws at the end of the day the most
useful money laundering tool though it's
the dollar bill the most useful way to
purchase things anonymously the dollar
bill right now how about online now
let's talk about dollar bills but
bitcoins digital's or criminals are
expanding their empire online since the
hard dollar bill can be Kamp cannot be
used digitally and honest anonymously or
can it if you take your cash money and
you walk into Walgreens CVS or some sort
of drug store in the United States you
can put down your 100% anonymous cash to
buy a money pack card or a PayPal card
it's gonna cost you five dollars to do
this think of this as your anonymous tax
so with money pack or PayPal cash card
you can either pay somebody with a
number on the card so you never even
have to go to through PayPal or you can
load it to an unverified PayPal account
and spend away done your cash spent at
Walgreens or CVS boom laundered then you
can buy goods or services online and
you're all set clean and extremely
simple with Bitcoin you can do similar
things but you can never run away from
that transaction ID that links you to
the transaction and the global net of
all transactions even if you change your
public key and transfer money out no
matter what you do this is tracked so
just like bouncing IDs around you you
you're still able to be tracked so you
can walk into any store load up a car
with cash and that's it it's incredibly
simple you don't even need an ID or
anything to do this stuff you just have
to pay the five dollar anonymous tax to
PayPal so that they can pay their law
and their officials to keep the world
turning so bottom line Bitcoin privacy
give me a break if anything Bitcoin
really needs more privacy to put it on
par with the dollar bill public keys
should be scrambled automatically or
passed through it's something like tour
and anything like that so Bitcoin really
could be private at that point then sure
people would have some ground to talk on
at least the problem however is this
rumor that bitcoin is totally anonymous
and provide it keeps being spread when
Bitcoin is not private or anonymous
people are also you know extremely quick
to forget that cash is the king when it
comes to laundering or funding criminal
activity I mean not Bitcoin I'm come on
guys in the end all these silly
regulations in the name of money
transmission and laundering just a joke
I mean the reasoning backing up these
regulations are purely empty and they're
being made by people who don't actually
understand bitcoins privacy model and
are being made to people who don't
actually understand Bitcoin and it's
privacy model either the New York
hearings that we were just watching not
too long ago and these Bitcoin
testimonials were also you know made by
people who had a stake in getting
Bitcoin regulated because their
businesses stood to gain massive growth
if Bitcoin could indeed be regulated
especially right there in New York all
of them had this characteristic so it's
no doubt that these people were for
Bitcoin regulation because it would help
them now the reason I bring up
regulation and privacy is they go hand
in hand with more regulation privacy
will go away I had one of my philosophy
teachers that went so far as to say
every bit of legislation is your is a
right being taken away so every law is
the taking away of some right of yours
and you pretty much can make that
argument with any form of rate
legislation and regulation here for sure
will be that because the regulation
that's in question is regulation that
gathers identity on an information on
your users to help fight this you know
quote unquote money laundering so again
the bottom line the current privacy
model for Bitcoin is
simply a new model it's not really more
private than the you know model that we
use today it just can't be constantly
monitored as easily it can't it can even
be constantly monitored though it's just
not simple it's gonna be somewhat
cumbersome it's gonna cost a lot more
CPU power to do it
but no matter what it's less private and
less anonymous than cash for sure if you
really want a month launder money you're
gonna do cash still if you want to
commit a crime you should still use cash
there's no way you would use use Bitcoin
it's traceable right you paying cash not
traceable and if you need to do
something online you would load up a
money pack or a PayPal card or something
of that sort so you know and all you
have to do there don't forget is you
have to pay your five-dollar fee which
goes towards lobbying to keep it
possible since it's highly profitable to
allow for something like this especially
if you run an oligopoly for it so
anyways that's going to conclude cohen
privacy as you can see i'm somewhat uh
have a little bit of an opinion on the
matter so i love try to leave most of
that out on the original going over the
paper but i do think it's important to
you know point out just the hypocrisy
here on you know regulating bitcoin when
it's like if we need to regulate bitcoin
we need to regulate the heck out of the
dollar bill because that is where money
is laundered and that is where if you
really want to commit crimes and be
anonymous you use cash and I mean people
are committing crimes with cash every
day you think your waiter is claiming
all of your tips nope they're not doing
that
you think people selling stuff on
Craigslist are claiming that on their
taxes nah come on give me a break
eBay not if it doesn't exceed twenty
thousand only until very recently has
that been in a requirement either so I
mean come on so anyways I think this is
just pathetic that this is even on the
topic here because Bitcoin is very
traceable right now if anything we
really need Bitcoin to be more private
and at that time if you made Bitcoin
more private and then you operated a
money transmission business then I
understand why you should be regulated
but at the moment no that's absurd so
anyways if you guys have a your own
opinion on
mater feel free to leave it below as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions until
next time